never underestimate someone by their
appearance such a classic adage that has
stood the test of time now while it's
true in reality it's an anime where we
see it taken to extremes seriously how
many of the super cool and badass
characters in anime are old men people
who look frail and washed up by all
means end up being some of the most
overpowered monsters in their respective
series today i'm going to be sharing
some moments where old men and anime
showcase their power and did a little
flexing of their own because those young
gun protagonists and rivals can't claim
those moments it's exclusively their own
right let's open things up with bleach
it could be because the sequel is
inching closer and closer but i feel
that it's also because bleach is one of
the most stereotypical representations
of the old man character in yamamoto the
leader of the goat day 13 gets his time
to shine in real combat towards the
climax of the fake goddess taunak where
he stands fully prepared to face aizen
unfortunately for him though aizen has
prepared a secret weapon to deal with
him having his powers sealed off by one
device yamamoto decides to give the
aaron carr a good old beating yeah who
says blue should be all about magical
swords when physical combat pardoned by
centuries of training manages to let
yamamoto obliterate his supposed counter
take note that one device had also come
from a presumed off-screen win against
kensei so this guy's no slouch if you
want to see more of yamamoto in action
get ready for the thousand-year blood
war arc where he'll finally unleash his
full power in the upcoming battles
since we're on the topic of samurai and
shonen anime why not continue with
guinta
being one of the four devas of kabuki
district jirocho's appearance alone will
be enough to send warning bells blaring
against any opponent however any title
or nickname an anime character has to
hype him will eventually have to be put
to the test for jirocho he gets the
chance to do so in a battle against the
series protagonist in episode 211 of
gintama fueled by rage kintoki lashes
out and wastes no time nailing jirocho
with quick attacks he gets the first hit
in and we're treated to a visual
spectacle of swords clashing the fans
immediately noticed that something was
wrong kintoki was in full attack mode
but jirocho simply brushed everything
off with his khan parries then he easily
turns the tides and hands gintoki one of
the most decisive defeats he's ever
received up to that point of the show
easily defending his title and showing
our protagonist an important lesson in
approaching combat
next up is a fairy tale moment
you know there was a time when things
were a lot simpler in fairy tale just
fun and easy guild adventure sandwiched
between long and serious arcs one such
serious arc was the guild war between
fairy tale and phantom lord well there
were lots of battles but in the end it
came down to guild master jose taking on
some of the best fairy tale had to offer
at that point urza gray and elfman those
three didn't fare too well against a
wizard saint like jose thankfully who
else to come to the rescue but good old
makrov there was a lot of trash talking
between the two masters of the battling
guilds but even jose's best efforts at
defeating makarov proved futile against
the latter's ultimate magic fairy lore
this is a great moment and a nice debut
for makarov we haven't seen much of this
guy before but this extended squash
fight would teach people not to
underestimate this jolly old man and we
haven't heard anything out of jose since
that total annihilation
we can take a trip back in time with a
helsing moment
when talking about badass anime butlers
people would unsurprisingly gravitate
towards sebastian but i think hell sings
walter deserves some love too it just so
happens that he gets overshadowed by the
crazier members of the cast but this
battle butler has a main streak of his
own all you have to see is how
effortless he makes carnage seem with
this moment in the anime it's a complete
180 turn as his calm walk turns into
flawless massacre masterfully using his
wires he makes short work of everyone in
sight it didn't matter that they're
relentlessly shooting at him walter just
goes on doing what he does best and all
the time he's just toying with the
opposition people say that we should
look out for alu guard but it turns out
that the whole helsing organization down
to the retainer is just full of
dangerous badasses
but hey speaking of badasses how about i
introduce you to the sponsors of this
video expressvpn it's the premiere vpn
service that will allow you to bypass
those pesky region locks and enjoy shows
you wouldn't normally be able to access
legally i started using expressvpn and i
never looked back i recently used it to
watch some killer kill fights just open
expressvpn and select the united states
server and boom now you can use it to
watch hundreds of different anime which
aren't available in your region and it
does all of this without slowing your
internet speeds down whatsoever i can
stream animate with blazing fast speeds
in hd quality and never experience any
buffering with expressvpn you can also
browse the internet with the maximum
security that a vpn can provide that
includes hiding your location and
protecting you against the scourge of
attacks on privacy that are becoming
more and more prevalent as the days go
by and all you have to do is head on to
my description box and follow the
instructions to download expressvpn or
just go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube with expressvpn see a brand
new internet without limits start your
trial on the number one vpn service now
let's proceed with a moment from hunter
hunter
[Applause]
yeah you all knew this was coming right
what better example of an old character
showing off than putting the spotlight
on netero once more nutero versus meruem
not quite because i want to feature
something that's less talked about thus
we talk about netero versus beto looking
at how kite got absolutely crushed you'd
have thought that this could have been
more of a fight but no the whole
sequence just went by in slow-mo along
with chilling music and letting the
moment sink in despite being one of the
strongest characters in the series
beethoven never knew what hit them and
otero simply brushed his opponent away
in one of the most disrespectful ways
possible
[Music]
never count an old man out especially
one who's a fan of doom
isn't that right start though the most
dangerous character in the series sato
refuses to go down without a fight
resulting in this one-man army moment
from episode 12 of the series surrounded
by enemies sato decides to do the most
logical thing and simply go gung-ho on
everyone it's like one of those
hollywood thriller shootouts except now
you're not supposed to be rooting for
the one doing the shooting but he did it
just also seamlessly so methodically so
smoothly seeing sato move around like
he's 16 as opposed to 60 it's quite a
thing to marvel at i can't help but be
caught up in the action as he so
flawlessly defeats everyone in sight and
contrary to his claim that the skirmish
tied him out he sure didn't seem wasted
when he unloaded on all those enemies
now this is a good way to push the main
antagonist with the ending of the series
on the horizon the final showdown will
be a sight to see
let's continue with another one-man army
moment this time from fma
i know i know king bradley in terms of
appearance isn't exactly what you'd
equate as an old man but officially he
is 60 and you know that i couldn't pass
off a chance to show off this awesome
moment you know what i'm talking about
don't you the time king bradley stood
solo against an entire army blockade
yeah there's nothing stopping his charge
not tanks not bullets and definitely not
pathetic soldiers who look completely
scared at what he was doing the way king
bradley just rushes in not a damn given
to the opposition would make anyone
think he's just playing with these
enemies playing a merciless game in the
most spectacular fashion possible where
else can you see a guy destroying tanks
in close quarters and slicing through
bullets or while looking completely
unfazed it's really impressive to think
that at this point king bradley is way
past his physical prime imagine what
pique bradley could have done
we wrapped this up with an iconic moment
from one piece
[Music]
you can't think of a better ending than
this whitebeard's appearance at aces
execution looked to be a beacon of hope
however the old captain finds himself
overwhelmed by the relentless assault of
the marines as well as a kainu anyone
would have been rendered helpless
against hundreds of different kinds of
wounds but this is whitebeard we're
talking about those would be nowhere
near enough to put him out of commission
and he soon gets a second win before
flexing his strength in an earth-shaking
display wiping the floor on the entire
marine squad even in his super weakened
state whitebeard still manages to come
out on top looking as cool as he could
be and standing triumphantly against
everyone speaking of standing up though
by the end of this arc he's cemented as
one of the most badass old men in battle
shonen but i think we can leave that one
for another time for now let's look back
and appreciate this astonishing moment
of endurance and power
[Music]
and that does it for this list eight
moments where old men showcased their
power and made it known that they
wouldn't lose to the young guns is there
another moment that you'd like to share
go and hit the comments section and
let's hear about it also if you're up
for more videos you can check out the
channel for more content you may also
connect with the channel on social media
as links to the discord channel
instagram and patreon should be in the
description box don't forget to check
out our sponsors of this video
expressvpn all you have to do is click
the link in the description box or go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube for a three month free trial
i hope you had fun thanks for watching
the video and i'll see you next time